in El Paso this morning the border
patrol is launching new operations to
find and expel migrants who entered the
United States illegally State officials
in Texas have called up more National
Guard troops to deal with an expected
Russia migrants this week 1500 federal
troops will start arriving at the
southern Border tomorrow Manuel Hawkins
is in Brownsville Texas Manuel good
morning
good morning Nate those sweeps you've
referenced in El Paso started early this
morning authorities are trying to remove
certain migrants while title 42 is still
in effect here where we are in the
Brownsville area over the last several
weeks they've been seeing about 2 000
migrant arrivals per day some are being
processed in the facility you see behind
me still GOP led states say the Biden
Administration is not doing enough
at this Brownsville border crossing at
the southern tip of Texas hundreds of
migrants have been lining up for
processing in the days preceding the end
of title 42. the pandemic era policy
that allows the government to expel
migrants to prevent the spread of covet
I do feel that we're as prepared as we
can be a replacement plan for the
measure could be in place as soon as
today CBS News has learned the Biden
Administration is working to finalize a
new regulation that would disqualify
migrants from Asylum if they failed to
request protection in another country on
their way to the U.S it would bar most
non-mexican migrants from Asylum if they
enter the U.S without permission a
violation would subject them to Swift
deportation a five-year banishment from
the U.S and potential criminal
prosecution if they try to re-enter
meanwhile Republican Governor Greg
Abbott announced Monday the deployment
of a new National Guard unit the Texas
Tactical border Force to combat border
crossings in the State and overnight
posted this video proclaiming this
border crossing in Brownsville is now
wired shut as the policy debates
continue border cities and many other
shelters have become overwhelmed we've
been here three days already it's
difficult because we don't have anything
to eat we have hundreds of migrants like
24 year old Demario Jones have been
waiting across the border near San Diego
since last week many without food or
water just want to go to the U.S to get
a work to change my life and live a good
life
the White House said yesterday President
Biden would veto a GOP scripted bill
that would revive some trump-era border
initiatives including resuming
construction of a border wall Gail
thank you Manny